there were two things that i really
needed the first was information on my
city from people i trusted
where do you live which bank do you join
what's a tv license um and then the
second piece was how do you recreate
your network from scratch welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring
upwards labs and hillel at stanford for
episode 275
i'm honored to have with us lynne
greenberg the founder and ceo of pivot
enterprise
lynn is the founder and ceo of pivot a
social app designed to reduce turnover
and improve the well-being of relocated
remote and transient employees
prior lynn worked at bloomberg lp in
london and then as a senior associate at
autonomy ventures
where she procured startup deal flow
manage teams and drove value creation
for portfolio companies
she currently serves as the vp of panels
for the new york venture community the
nyvc
and mentors and advises at women in
business and yeshiva university
astia angels london and partners and
athletic venture advisors
lynn greenberg thank you so much for
joining me how are you
thank you for having me i'm michael
wow wonderful staying staying healthy
and safe in
tel aviv yup yup staying safe and
healthy you know we're at a lockdown now
but but it's great because i get to
still talk to you over over this
wonderful
platform so thank you for making the
time to do this what i'm especially
excited to talk about is
your insight into the remote working
employee turnaround satisfaction
happiness success whatever it may be
i think that it's you know it's a
fascinating field to be in especially
in 2020 even though you started all the
way back in 2017 i believe
er with pivot but before that i want to
go all the way back to
to the early days you've done a
multitude of of fascinating things from
from venture capital to advising and
panels
to now being the co-founder and ceo but
you're also a soccer player
right i was um
tell me about that how do you turn yeah
i i always love sports i think um
you know part of it was uh you know i
grew up with two brothers
um and so you know i was always
surrounded by it
and um and and really enjoyed it but i
also really
loved the being on a team and being
exposed to
different types of people and um you
know the lessons that i learned as
as an athlete um certainly coincide with
you know what i deal with on an everyday
basis as as a founder
so um really grateful for that i wish i
i got to play a little bit more than i
do right now um
but but hopefully you know in 2021
uh we'll be able to pick it back up
again
i love that so taking back to 2017 you
come up with this idea for pivot
and you're the founder and ceo what is
pivot
what are some insights that you've
accumulated from your past experiences
that bring you to this
to this realization
yeah so this actually um will go back
all the way to when i graduated from
college
uh and three weeks later i relocated to
london
to work for bloomberg and i was 21 years
old
didn't know anyone and face the issue
that all people do when moving to a new
and unfamiliar place
which is how do you go about making your
new city feel like home
and there were there were two things
that i really needed
the first was information on my city
from people i trusted
where do you live which bank do you join
um what's a tv license um and then the
second piece was how do you recreate
your network from scratch
because as anyone that moves knows it's
friends you need the most when you're
adjusting
to a new and unfamiliar place so this
was something that
i was just curious about spoke to other
expats
at bloomberg london which is the
international hub and
found that it was a much bigger problem
than just myself
went on you know dating apps went uh
tried meet up tried facebook groups
nothing really seemed to you know fill
the void
and so started taking classes um
you know to to try to figure out a prop
to a way to solve this problem
and so um long story short we launched
pivot in 2017 as a consumer app
for people moving and traveling to help
acclimate in their new city
we were launched on the app store and
google play in new york and london for
about six months
we had 10 000 users when we started
getting approached by corporations
and they said you know we came across
your platform
love what you're building it's actually
something we're struggling with
internally with our relocated employees
and business travelers
is this something you'd be interested in
building for businesses
so we went back to the drawing board and
what we found
was that actually corporations on
average spend about
ninety thousand dollars relocating a
single employee
much more if you're an executive ninety
thousand dollars for one employee
exactly yep um and
and because there's no social component
helping these people acclimate
about a third of those people quit their
job within a year
or move back home because of social
reasons so
when we found that out we refactored our
app to fit a business model
and that's what we've been working on
ever since
unbelievable walk me through the journey
of
getting this product market fit in
validation from another
another avenue right and literally
pivoting your company pivot
to that what as the ceo was that a
difficult decision an easy decision
what what was going on over there it's
always it's always a
you know a difficult decision when you
make something
um you know from so much apart from a
first of all
a part of something that you went
through personally um
and then put so much heart and soul into
to saying okay
maybe we should you know pivot and and
go in a different direction
um but you know certainly what i learned
through venture capital
and as being a founder is you have to
stay very true to your mission
but you need to listen to your customers
and you need to be able to
you know adjust um you know very quickly
and um if if you can't then you're not
going to survive
and so you know our goal has always been
to enable give people a platform where
they could take
um you know life-changing opportunities
in unfamiliar places
and expand their outlooks without
thinking twice and so this started out
being
you know on a consumer app for business
travelers backpackers
relocated employees but ultimately what
we came to realize
was we we would be able to do this more
efficiently
if we we went over to a business to
business
solution and um you know it would just
be a different way to go to market
so so tell me a little bit about what's
happening today in terms of
relocations more tangibly so i
understand that you know
on on average businesses spend and a
humongous amount of money
on helping their employees relocate
but what are some of the really core
challenges
that pivot thinks that can help solve
in that domain to make it easier for
both the you know the employees but also
the employers
yeah so this is something that we've
been spending a lot of our time on
through kovit is really just you know
understanding
what this new normal is going to look
like and the new concerns of our our
clients and so
there's a couple of things the first
thing is that one in five americans
have relocated or knows someone that has
relocated due to covet
and you know a lot of that is because of
the the change in the work environment
and so we're in the beginning stages of
testing out
whether you know because employee
benefits like
happy hour and unlimited snacks in the
office
and and office space is no longer really
relevant
if something like pivot you know is
something that these employees
these employers want to give to their
employees that are
you know socially isolated um and and
relocating so frequently
so so that's the first thing that that
we're tapping into is
do we have a place in this work from
anywhere environment um which we
we think we do the other interesting
component is we've been speaking with
you know heads of global mobility uh
around the world we spoke with
um you know the head of global mobility
at apple
and um we said to him you know is are
you guys
thinking of you know working remotely
when all of this is said and done and he
said you know no for two reasons
the first is it's really difficult to
create a strong company culture
digitally
the second is how do you train employees
um
you know from a from a digital
standpoint and so
um actually what we've been seeing
is from the relocation standpoint the
relocation management companies
have seen an increase in rfps during
this
so we're finding that companies are
taking this time to reevaluate their
strategies
and relocation is very much a part of
the mix when things get to be safe
so very few have been halted more so
there's a there's a
larger backlog for when it's safe to
travel
so um you know i do think that
you know people are going to return to
the office i think that it's going to be
you know a little bit more flexible in
regards to how many days you have to
a week you spend in the office but i do
think relocations are going to move as
as scheduled um and i think
it's it's going to increase in the sense
that you know i think people's um
working habits is going to allow them
and to live in
uh you know much different uh types of
ways and
in places around the world and i think
that um you know employers are going
to have to cater to that and their
benefits that makes a lot of sense so
what
does pivot actually do what what would i
experience
as an employee relocating and
having my employer enroll me i guess and
pivot and the services so what what
experience would it be getting which
would help
me make the new place like home and and
potentially have less churn with it with
my
with my existing company yeah so from a
relocation standpoint
we can take my example so i was moving
from new york to london
essentially how it would work is as soon
as i found out
that i was moving uh i'd get access to
pivot
welcome three access to family members
because actually
70 of relocations fail not because the
actual employee has difficulty
acclimating
with the spouse and you know the family
members
that makes perfect sense exactly that's
the first part of the mix so
they could open up pivot um you know
using my example
new york to london you could open our
find network feature
which shows you all of our relocated and
mobile employees around the world
so whether you're with pepsi or hsbc
or a small startup everyone is on the
same platform
you could search london up top ahead of
your move
you know see who you who's there and
then filter it down to find
you know people that are from your
hometown university
workplace same language also moving with
a family
all for the purpose of getting you know
the most trusted information
um and connecting with people who you
may want to meet socially
and then the second feature that we have
is a community mastering platform
which connects people based on interests
goals and passions
so everything from moving with a family
to london
to new york knicks fans in london to
vegans in london
and this is actually a place where you
can ask and give recommendations
create events and gatherings and connect
uh based on general discussion
right so is the network that you're
building within pivot is that mainly
you know the net is the network effect
mainly relocated people
helping other relocated people or is
there also an incentive
for you know the average you know person
that that works in a similar industry to
perhaps
be on the platform because if i move now
let's say to london
um i want to meet i guess as to have as
many people
to for to potentially meet or to have
common interests with right
exactly and so you know the more people
that we speak to and
of course what we found on our consumer
app was the fact of the matter is as an
adult
it's difficult to to meet new friends a
lot of times
and so um you know this goes way beyond
um our core need which you know is the
biggest pain point which is among
relocated employees
but we're also seeing this and we've
been asked from day one to extend it to
business travelers
maybe you're not a relocated employee
but you're a consultant
that's spending five days a week in a
new city and you face a lot of the same
issues
that relocated employees do or now so
you know maybe you're a work from
anywhere employee now
and you're relocating on your own um you
know those are
uh especially now where you're not
meeting people at bars
and you're not attending gatherings what
can employers do
to give you that sense of community
wherever you are in the palm of your
hands
um for a low price that makes perfect
sense so what are some of the you know
really surprising things that you've
learned
as you observe you know the consumer
behavior through pivot because i think
that that's a
you know a really fascinating place to
to examine that you know
most most companies don't necessarily
have the the data to even look at
so so that's just it so i think the the
the most interesting thing that i've
found
when moving over to b2b is that there's
just a
lack of kpis and metrics around success
so you'll have the head of global
mobility at you know some large
organizations
what does a successful post look like
and they won't necessarily be able to
tell you
um it's not necessarily based around
churn
it's not necessarily based around you
know how successful they are
in terms of production and so one of the
things that we started working on
through kovid
is we brought on a social network
scientist and we're
speaking we're working with a couple of
academics that study the future of work
and the the purpose of that is taking
their past research
and saying okay what can we do
based on what you guys have learned and
what we see
to create the first human success
formula
using pivot um so our whole theory is
that
you know moving people and moving things
from a to b is very self-explanatory
but the human side is walking the cracks
and that's why there's such a big hole
and so we're trying to create a formula
on pivot
where we can say to employers if your
employees do a before they move
and x and y you know within six months
after they move
then we can predict that they'll be 20
more successful in their post
and here are the kpis that will gauge
success
um and so i think that's one of the
biggest things you know that
that i found was that you know this
didn't exist
and i think it's just gonna create you
know a whole new sense of
of crystallization and um
and and and will help in well-being you
know substantially
no no that sounds that makes perfect
sense to me
if you can imagine or paint a world you
know five ten years from now
of how people experience their
relocation
whether it's you know with pivot inside
or without it but
what is this ideal situation then
where an employee would experience a
fruitful relocation
so as i i said from um you know the
beginning the the mission is
always to create a platform where people
can take life-changing opportunities
without thinking twice you know social
problems um
should not be a concern um and and so
the the idea is to give them pivot and
to
to give them a formula and to give them
a sense of community wherever they are
um ultimately what we're trying to
you know solve is is that sense of
belonging um because
you know feeling at home is really
feeling like you belong
and belonging is not necessarily fitting
in um
belonging is really in our minds feeling
like you can
be who you are wherever you are and feel
comfortable with that person
right and so i think if you can unlock
that
um you know wherever people are i think
there can be
you know much bigger implications and
and um
and i think it could be really impactful
that that makes perfect consent
very very insightful thank you lynn i
have to ask you
you've been part of so many different
organizations as a mentor
as a strategic advisor what were the
biggest takeaways that that you take
from you know the mentorship side now to
being the pers
perhaps the mentee side things that
patterns that you've observed
throughout your journey that other you
know
young founders are doing now you know
you're experiencing yourself so
what how does the puzzle piece together
yeah
it's really interesting and part of the
reason why i mentor is because i feel so
fortunate that i've been able to make a
lot of mistakes as a founder
and see a lot made as an investor i was
an investor before i started pivot
for that reason of kind of learning the
other side of things
what makes startups tick what makes them
fail and um
you know it's it's different as much as
you learn it from the other side
when you do it as an entrepreneur it's
it's from a whole different lens
um and so you know the i could
i could go on for days of the number of
lessons learned
you know that i've experienced but um as
i said before i think one of the
the main things is um you know being on
your toes
in the sense of staying true to your
mission but being able to adapt quickly
to cut new customer needs um
you know really being able to um
emphasize enough staying you know really
close to your customers
um you know for our consumer app
specifically we built out
features that required money and time
that didn't need to be spent
um just thinking because we had gone
through it and that's something that we
wanted
that that's something that everyone
wanted and you know
really encourage people to you know
create
kind of customer support groups and and
whatnot
and really keep a close tab on what they
want what they need
what they're doing you know really find
out whatever you can about
um them um that's incredible
no no i i that that's a that's that's
definitely very very wise and i
and i'm looking forward to taking those
lessons and implementing them on my
my own venture someday lynn i also want
to thank you for being so generous with
your time i think that what you're doing
with pivot is
it is fantastic and i can't see the
world
going back to anything close to what it
was before uh
i'm i'm presuming that relocation is
just going to
to magnify this understanding that
people can work from various locations
and a lot of
perhaps families or or single people
that have thought about relocating or
living different experiences
whether it's for personal reasons or
family reasons they'll
be able to venture out and do so and
there will be opportunity for all of
that and i think that
you know providing a safe space for them
to do that where they can
be both nurtured in a new community and
a new environment
through an app like pivot and provide
them a network of people that can
make the new place feel more like home i
think that's extremely smart
and this and the part about going back
to the companies providing those kpis
and those insights into helping them
and helping them keep and maintain those
employees that are relocating i think
that's
and that's just incredible so lynn thank
you very very much and before we end i
have to ask you the most important
question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
oh that's that's tough um
i would say that everyone that knows me
in the industry would say
probably say that i'm you know
determined um very passionate
and and um and trustworthy
i love that lynn thank you have a you
know a
great time with pivot continue making a
positive impact and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you so much and to you michael
thank you for having me